j'ai écrit donc le 30 avril également
préfet donc justement pour lui dire ça
son absence de soutien et puis justement
lui demandant les remboursements de de
tous ces dégâts
ensuite voyons cela et puis après longue
discussion avec ma famille vous imaginez
que voilà c'est très difficile de
continuer à vivre cela juste pour dire
il y a deux semaines lors du du week-end
du 8 mai mon fils qui habite Paris
est venu passer trois jours nous étions
à la terrasse d'un café le dimanche midi
donc en public et une personne de ce
collectif qui a dit bien entendu on est
des idées d'extrême droite se diriger
vers moi je l'avais vu arriver mais bien
entendu j'avais tourné la tête pour
justement ne pas le fixer du regard
il est venu directement vers nous en
m'insultant mais t'as pas fini de
le bazar à Saint-Brevin avec tes
migrants enfin bon puis il a continué et
puis tout en continuant en essayant de
faire croire à tout le monde que c'était
moi-même qui avait mis l'incendie donc à
mes deux véhicules et à ma maison voilà
et il a fini par par partir et donc j'ai
relaté ça la presse pour expliquer
pourquoi justement on ne voulait plus
vivre ça et puis ma femme pas non plus
rencontrer ce genre de personne et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
décidé de démissionner de ma fonction de
d'élus et de quitter et bien entendu
cette ville voilà qui m'avait accueilli
il y a il y a 32 ans
j'ai envoyé ma démission au préfet
le mardi qui a suivi et en fait il m'a
appelé le lendemain
voilà on a discuté je lui ai dit que
j'avais pas senti le soutien de l'État
ça répond ça a été mais si on vous a
soutenu lorsqu'il y a eu les
manifestations
j'ai tout fait j'ai mis en fin de compte
trois compagnies de CRS pour éviter les
dégâts j'ai envoyé également un
sous-préfet d'astre la procureur qui
était présente sur site donc j'ai agi
voilà ça a été ça ça a été sa réponse
voilà faut savoir que le le préfet quand
il a écrit dans la presse qu'il m'a vu
régulièrement au téléphone
le jour où j'ai énormément de mission
c'est la deuxième fois je l'avais au
téléphone je l'ai eu la première fois le
journal incendie la seconde fois
lorsque je vais je vais donner ma
démission quant à Monsieur le sous-pré
fet je lis au téléphone comme je vous
l'ai dit le jour de l'incendie depuis
plus jamais